turning now to the pandemic there are
huge global differences over which
countries have access to covid vaccines
just 10 percent of people in africa have
received a single dose compare that to
63 percent in north america or 62
percent in europe now a south african
startup is getting support from the
world health organization to replicate
moderna's vaccine deborah patta got a
look at their efforts
a pair of nondescript warehouses in a
dusty part of cape town
is the unlikely home to a revolution i
love it you don't know what's behind
these roller doors
inside the air locked sterile rooms
you'll find a band of rebels albeit in
white lab coats passionate about using
science to change the world so this is
where the manufacturing will start
afrigen's managing director says their
aim is to overcome the vaccine
inequalities laid painfully bare by the
covet pandemic although these massive
efforts to scale up production in
facilities in the high income countries
those vaccines first vaccinated people
in the high-income countries
so african countries had to wait as a
result less than five percent on the
continent are fully vaccinated
technical director dr karen fenner says
the pandemic was a wake-up call because
it made us realise if we don't step up
and do it ourselves no one else is going
to do it
after pleading with big farmer to share
their recipes these scientists are done
waiting and have taken the development
of a covered vaccine into their own
hands
aphrogen is replicating moderna's mrna
vaccine together with vits university in
johannesburg who have mastered the
difficult science needed to manufacture
mrna despite moderna's stated commitment
to global vaccine access they have not
given their permission we can legally
take this vaccine up to clinical trials
without infringing any intellectual
property but then you have a problem so
we would ideally want to have a license
agreement with moderna the dream here is
not just to replicate but innovate the
vaccine to create a freeze-dried version
that doesn't require cold storage the
world health organization is backing
this effort so that africa can reduce
its reliance on outside companies
but so many health experts globally have
said it couldn't be done africa can't do
it they can't produce an mrna vaccine
i think we have a surprise for the rest
of the world we can
and we will
the kind of determination needed on this
covert battlefront
it takes rebels in lab coats to even the
field
for cbs mornings debra patter cape town
rebels and lab coats and they look like
they want to get it done